Good day, everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn from the University
of Southern California and the Big Data to
Knowledge Training Coordinating Center.
And I'd like to welcome you to this.
Our final, in our series, of a guide to the
fundamentals of data science seminar series.
Today, we're very delighted to have Dr. Patricia
Flatley Brennan, director of the National
Library of Medicine and Interim Associate
NIH director for data science, speaking on
data science at the NIH current state and
future directions.
We're very delighted to have Dr. Brennan,
who is the former Lillian L. Moehlman Bascom
Professor at the School of Nursing and College
of Engineering at the University of Wisconsin,
Madison.
Where she led the living environments laboratory
at the Wisconsin Institutes for Discovery.
Developed Computer Link, an electronic network
designed to reduce isolation improved self-care
amongst home health care patients.
And directed heart care, directed health design.
She has a long list of accolades, and her
CV must be pages and pages and chapters long.
In particular, most recently, she has been
the director of the National Library of Medicine
since August of 2016.
And recently, as of January of 2017, took
on the role of the Interim Associate NIH director
for data science, the ads office that many
of you are familiar with.
And as part of that, she is in a leadership
position for the BD2K enterprise, many of
which you participate in.
So we're very delighted to get some insights
from her about the current state of data science
at the NIH.
What future directions hold through data science
at the NIH for biomedical research, progress
in all manner of data mining, and computation,
and informatics, et cetera.
So we're very delighted to have Dr. Brennan.
And I would like to ask you, that if you have
any questions for Dr. Brennan, please use
the Go To webinar question submission feature,
and you can submit your questions, and about
10 minutes before the hour, we'll take those
questions.
I'll read them off to her, and she'll get
a chance to answer.
So without further delay, Dr. Brennan, thank
you so much for joining us.
Thanks very much and I appreciate the kind
introduction.
I thank all of you for taking time out of
your day today.
If it's as beautiful where you are as it is
here in Washington, you're missing a bright
sunny, but rather hot day, outside to participate
in this last of the big data science seminars,
held now for almost for a year.
I want to say how happy I am to be a part
of this seminar series, and how glad I am
to be at this point in time.
Certainly, there have been some notable speakers
that have gone ahead of me, bringing you both
technical solutions, I hope, and new perspectives
in thinking about data and data science.
My role today is to accomplish four things
with you.
First, I want to give you an update on what's
going on at NIH with data science.
There's many things.
It's a vibrant, active part of our mission.
Second, I want to provide you with some of
my views and perspectives on data science,
so you can understand how I'm approaching
this challenge, and perhaps, guide me with
your ideas of how to make sure we create a
robust infrastructure for discovery.
Third, I'm going to explain our near term
and at your
efforts, in both the intramural NIH campus
level investments, as well as our national
investments in data science.
And finally-- and I hope to actually save
even more time than the 10 minutes at the
end-- to get your thoughts and ideas about
how the NIH can facilitate data science, data
driven discovery, and the clinical practice,
and health improvement of our country, based
on investments in data driven resources.
I want you to think about what kind of services
would be needed in the future.
What kind of supports do you need?
Are you looking forward to certain types of
granting programs, certain types of methodological
issues?
Should we be thinking about workforce development.
Those kinds of resources I would very much
appreciate your guidance on.
And I'm going to ask Crystal and the organizers
if they can record all of the comments that
come in, even if we don't get to address all
of them in our conversation today.
Let me begin by taking you to the end.
Why do we actually want to invest in data
science?
We believe that fundamentally, data science
is a pathway to discovery, is a new and essential
pathway to discovery, and along that pathway
there are opportunities, there are challenges,
and there's a need for some direction.
The idea that data drives discovery is a fundamental
shift, not simply in the methods we use, but
in the way we conduct research.
And at NIH, this commitment is very strong,
and it begins at that highest level of leadership.
Dr. Collins has personally invested in how
to create the proper infrastructure for data
science.
The BD2K program, that was familiar to most
of you over the years, began as an inquiry
spurned on by the enormous amount of data
being generated through genomic and proteomic
studies in the late 90s and early 2000s.
A realization that we needed to enable biomedical
sciences to capitalize on the data being generated
by research communities.
And so the BD2K program launched after a series
of workshops held, that met with many different
sectors, many different stakeholders, and
came to focus on the idea that we needed to
provide training infrastructure.
We needed to stimulate all types of research
in new areas about data.
We needed to stimulate basic methodological
inquiry, as well as investment in the infrastructure
needed to support data.
And what you see on the screen here is our
home page for data science at NIH.
And I call your attention to the bar at the
bottom, which describes the data science community,
the big data to knowledge process, and the
comments.
The data science community is broader than
anyone ever expected, bringing in, not only
genomic space researchers, but also people
with advanced analytics, machine learning,
and artificial intelligence specialists.
Even bringing in engineers and computer scientists
and designing new data models, new kinds of
resources, and storage strategies.
In addition, the library sciences community
has played an increasingly large role as part
of the data science community with their skills
and curation standards setting, dissemination,
and collection management.
We organize a lot of the thinking around data
science, under the concept of a commons, and
we'll return to this
phrase several times, I know you've had other
discussions about it earlier throughout this
year.
From the perspective of the NIH, at this point
in time, is that commons is both a concept,
as well as a physical space.
And we'll be talking about some of the work
that's being done to set up the NIH commons.
The idea is the commons provides a safe harbor
for data to be stored, but also a pathway
for data to be accessed and used.
We envision that data commons is not only
serving a repository for data, but also as
a suite of services, resources for modeling,
for curation, and for establishing a good
catalog of data and information.
Let me speak to specifically about the BD2K
program right now, for that's what brought
a lot of people into this process.
As you know, the BD2K program was intended
to be about $125-$130 million initiative per
year, over about an eight year period.
And we're about halfway through this period.
At this time, with the departure of Phil Bourne
and the reorganization of the associate director
of data science office, we've had many discussions
with the NIH leadership about how to make
sure we're getting the yield and value out
of the NIH investment in the Big Data to Knowledge
Project.
We anticipate that this project will continue
from now through its intended target date
of 2021.
And the project is fully funded through this
period of time.
And yet, there are changes that are being
made.
Those changes are summarized in a blog post
that we provided on February the 23rd.
The link to the blog post is on the screen
in front of you.
But essentially, let me summarize what's in
that blog post.
First we have the BD2K program resources were
designed to provide extramural support, that
is out of NIH support, for data discovery,
data curation, data management.
We remain committed to all existing programs,
and so they will be funded at there originally
intended level.
All programs that are active-- this was as
of January, but continues through now-- all
programs that are active will be funded through
the end point of their period of time, many
of them winding up by August of 2018.
We added one new program funding this spring,
and that was an initiative on curation.
That had been released prior to the planned
pivoting of the BD2K program, and that was
that the announcements about the funding of
those new projects will come out during this
summer.
They are specifically targeting innovations
in curation, including some very exciting
uses of natural language processing to facilitate
automated curation.
We are also, at this time, considering and
putting together the think tank within NIH
to plan for future needs, including training,
research, infrastructure, and policy development.
What's important about this is during the
process of pivoting from the extramural program,
to the next phase of BD2K, we recognize that
we have a rapidly growing amount of data that
still lacks a safe place for storage.
So during this two year period of time, we
are investing more in creating NIH based resources
for our high value data sets and for access
for researchers to begin to compute on those
data sets.
I'll return to that those comments in a few
minutes, after we talk about, in
general, the process of discovery through
data.
But remember, I'm hoping that you will continue
to jot down your thoughts, and think about
how the NIH can foster data driven discovery
as you perceive it from your own workplace
and your own work career.
But let's pause for a moment and think about
where discoveries originate from.
And why the NIH should be investing in creating
an infrastructure for discovery.
Early discoveries of the health sciences were
originated through the process of experience.
An individual, a clinician, a healer, worked
with the patient, worked with a person in
need, made observations about what happened.
The response, hopefully an improvement, because
of that additional sunshine, certain herbs,
or maybe certain kinds of medication.
These processes of experience were translated
to written documents, and the pathway for
discovery became a one time experience with
an individual shared in a narrative or heuristic
fashion.
As we move to the late 18th, early 19th century,
we began to see the embracing of experimental
design as a pathway to discovery.
Experimental design had lots of advantages
that allowed us to focus specifically on phenomenon,
to maybe discern the pathway that explain
why certain phenomenon occurred in a certain
fashion or did not occur.
It let us determine which techniques work
better than others.
Increasingly, experiments also brought about
a perspective on science that allowed for
excluding, or controlling for, variability
in the process that was being observed by
ensuring that careful procedures were followed,
by ensuring that certain variables, certain
aspects of the phenomenon, were highlighted,
and others were not attended to.
And precision in measurement and understanding
allowed for a process of discovery.
This philosophy was a very-- what I would
call-- particularistic approach to discovery,
that essentially required the investigator
to design a priori, an experiment that had
the appropriate variables, the appropriate
manipulations, and the appropriate controls,
and allowing and learning through prior studies
for example, or through study of the literature.
What aspects of the phenomenon needed to be
attended to, and what could be ignored?
Part of the value of experimentation was its
narrowness of focus.
But part of the limitation was its narrowness
of focus.
And increasingly, over time, experiments generated
more and more data.
As we moved into the 60s, in the US and around
the world, computation became an important
complement to the experimental design.
Computation now freed us from being too overly
restrictive on the number of variables that
could be observed and analyzed at the same
time.
And allowed for an increasing augmentation,
not only of the research process, but in the
cognition of the individual, who was trying
to understand phenomenon and plot the pathway
through.
We now are moving into, what I think of as,
the fourth generation of discovery processes.
And that is data driven discovery.
Here we are freed from the constraints that
experiments once required us to adhere to.
That is a
limitation in the number of variables, or
limitation in the consideration of what aspects
needs to be considered.
And it brings us to the ability to understand
phenomenon in context, in much greater detail.
The challenge of managing this information,
as a process of discovery, is going to require
changes in the way we think about the substrate,
the infrastructure, to support discovery.
When we think in a data driven era of discovery,
we're envisioning data as a substrate that
is both generated by experiments and observations,
and then becomes subsequently, later on, the
substance that future discoveries are rest
on.
So we see a process here of accelerating discovery,
activities conducted once, can generate data
that can be re-used many times.
Fundamentally, data driven discovery rests
on two aspects: data and computation.
I'm not going to go into too much depth about
the fair principles of data.
I'm sure they're well familiar to the audience
that we're speaking.
But for those of you who may be less familiar
with it, let me just say, straight forward,
that there is a acceptance around the world
that for data driven discovery, we must have
a quality of data that makes sure that those
data are findable, are accessible, are interoperable,
and reusable.
For data to be findable, we need to attend
to the labeling, the metadata, the curation
of the data to ensure it is locatable through
machine interaction.
That begins with making sure the data are
well labeled and cataloged and described in
a way that can be discovered.
Ensuring that data are accessible is not only
a technical challenge, but it's also a challenge
of ensuring that the authentication and authorization
to use data sets, is appropriately managed,
so that data are managed in a respectable
fashion.
Interoperability is that characteristic that
we trust will lead us to be able to link data
sets from more than one environment, from
more than one experiment, across several experiments.
The interoperability of data requires that
data be findable, that his terms be used in
a similar and consistent fashion.
But also that they be accessible through platforms
that allow the transmission of analytics,
as well as the transmission of the data themselves.
Fundamentally, in data driven discovery, the
principle of reusability governs what we do.
That is, we start from an original experiment
moving onto a recognition that the data generated
from one experiment, needs to be placed in
a storage strategy that is accessible to others.
But reusability, like our other three characteristics
of data, is not simply a technical challenge,
but its also a social challenge.
Reuseable data, and discovery driven by reuseable
data sets, is a shift in the way research
is done and valued.
Primary investigation often was considered
the hallmark of the best practices of research,
and secondary analysis, while useful, was
not often awarded the same level of respect
and consideration, in terms of its value.
Increasingly, we are now realizing, that one
single experiment-- even one that is designed
in a very complex fashion, engaging a lot
of investigators-- still doesn't yield all
of the findings that the data set generated
in the
experiment could yield.
And so we now need to think, not only how
to make that data reusable, but how to make
reusable data driven discovery approaches
to research, as valued, as useful for society
as our experimental models.
Computational challenges remain.
Data science is not simply statistics on steroids,
or bioinformatics with large groups, large
sets of data.
But really requires us to think about ways
we can bring in new kinds of analytics.
One of the values of data driven discovery,
is that we are freed of the assumptions that
must be met, in order to be able to use classic
statistics in [INAUDIBLE] models.
We are able now, to take data in its natural
form, and use that data in any way to help
discover by considering different approaches
to analytics.
And I call your attention to developments
in three areas that I find particularly promising.
Distributed analytics, machine learning, and
an optimization.
Distributed analytics allow us to essentially
bring analytic tools to where the data reside
and return the results of an analysis to be
compiled and integrated in the fashion.
This is a marked departure from our usual
multisite clinical trials models, where data
are collected in one place and gathered in
a central place, for subsequent analysis.
Distributed analytics have a power to be able
to look at different phenomenon over time,
but importantly, also have the promise of
ensuring privacy preservation, so the data
themselves are not transported, only the analytics
from the data.
Machine learning strategies, particularly
deep learning, bring a chance to understand
data from its basic discovery model, and then
require a interpretation based on the frameworks
and the theories that are brought by domain
science.
The values of machine learning is that it
lies in the fact that the patterning that
is assessed, is not constrained by certain
underlying assumptions of the data, but rather
can be brought forward based on the existence
of the data itself.
Essentially, we have a semantic free discovery
strategy, that later requires interpretation.
This, by way, is also one of the downfalls.
Many machine learning results are difficult
to explain to domain scientists or clinicians,
and therefore, require a longer pathway to
explanation.
Optimization is an approach brought in from
operations research that allows us to look
at pathways through data sets, discovering
from the millions of possible trajectories,
for example, or the millions of possible samples,
that could be drawn.
Which are the ones that would be most promising?
Optimization gives us a chance to approach
data in a more principled fashion, so that
we can make the best use of the analytic powers
available for the data scientists discovery.
I see particular promise and visualization
strategies, and to a particular visual analytics,
the use of analytical display and the use
of visual displays of data, as an assistance
in the process of analysis, and also in depicting
results.
One of the challenges of data science is that,
while it's not restricted to very large data
sets, it's often employed in the analysis
of very large data sets, ones that are not
human readable, or too large for a human to
comprehend.
And so the visualization tools allow us the
opportunities to explore these data sets and
examine and bring in human judgment as needed.
It's important to spend a little bit of time
talking about some of the computational challenges
for the management of data.
We have a great need to put in place, good
business processes, that allow for access,
access control, management, and the attempt
to preserve the proper alignment of the permission
to use the data with the individual choosing
to use it.
Business management processes are also needed
to help us to anticipate the value of data
set, and the potential cost of curation, and
the cost of reuse of data sets, so we can
put proper pricing strategies in place.
Another management challenges that we face,
is the preservation of the provenance of analytical
strategies.
The enormous size of data sets and the teams
working with them, often leads us to having
a very confused pipeline and the increasing
reliance on pipeline approaches to maintaining
the history of the analysis done with a particular
data set, will enable us to discover it in
a more reliable fashion.
Finally, maintaining version control of the
data set, I believe presents a particular
challenge, that I think the National Library
of Medicine may have some particular skills
to solve.
One of the things that we realized, is once
data sets are acquired, new investigators
bring new enrichment strategies to them, and
require, and make modifications that may be
well understood by that individual.
This brings to us in need for managing version
control, for having the proper tools in place,
so that a basic data set remains intact, but
the enhancements and enrichments done by other
investigators, also remain accessible to the
community as it emerges.
I'd like to talk to now, about where I see
the National Library of Medicine fitting into
this process.
About three years ago, at NIH, a study was
done reported to the director of NIH that
said, that the National Library of Medicine
should become the epicenter of data science
for the NIH.
Now epicenter has sort of a bad meeting, in
some places.
The center of an earthquake, or the center
of destruction, and I certainly hope the National
Library of Medicine does not become the center
of destruction.
But I do believe with our long history, over
almost 200 years, of support for discovery
in our country and around the world, the National
Library of Medicine will play an important
role in accelerating data science.
Let me show you a brief video that will introduce
you to some of the products and services at
the National Library of Medicine currently
is involved with.
And then we'll talk about how we're going
to be participating in the data driven discoveries
of the future.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
This video introduced you to some of our treasures
and some of our products.
I'm sure you're well familiar with PubMed,
many of you probably also use dbGaP.
Our PubMed, or citation database, has over
26 and 1/2 million citations to the biomedical
literature, or to articles, around the world.
And adds almost 1 million citations every
year.
Our resources are also though used by young
children and families around the world.
You saw Medline Plus.
You saw the [INAUDIBLE] young child, as he
heard the voice of a native healer, we preserve
the healing traditions of the country.
We also provide training.
We also provide various ways to make sure
our resources are used.
You might have been wondering why we shared
that slide of malaria and that cup of water
with the bugs in it.
We are trying to use our image processing
analysis to provide in the field detection
of different diseases, so that in under-resourced
country, we're able to take the knowledge
of the library into the decision making process
in the laboratory, as quickly as possible.
So we do primarily support research, but our
resources, driven by the need to support research,
are used globally.
4 million times a day to PubMed Central, 300,000
times a day to dpGaP.
Millions of individuals access our work.
And you saw pathogen detection process that's
now used every day by public health authorities
around the country, trying to determine the
exact nature of an E. coli or a listeria outbreak.
Essentially, our future bills and our passed,
and we are ready to take leadership in the
area of data science around the country.
But let me take you back to the very first
slides you saw.
We began indexing in 1838, and for almost
135 years, we worked to develop an index of
the medical literature, so they could be located
and discovered and used by researchers and
clinicians.
Starting in the 70s, we began to digitize
our indexing tools, so they could be accessed
and searched.
And then with the advent of the internet in
1984, we began to look at how our resources
could be used by individuals around the world,
without this mediation of a specialist, like
a librarian.
We face so many similar challenges today with
data, as we faced in the past with managing
the literature.
Making sure that we have access to it, making
sure our investigators know how to use it,
providing a pathway for people to report,
and present their findings of their research,
so we believe we will be able to manage and
support the due data driven discoveries.
I'd like to focus on five or six key areas,
that were guiding our plans and our investments
here.
The first is the development and determination
of high value data sets.
High value data sets are data sets that are
worthy of preservation because of their potential
for future discovery from them.
Now high value data set may be a data set
likely to be used by a lot of individuals--
you can think of the Framingham study or the
GTX resource-that's being developed through
the common fund as types of high value data
sets, or the model organism databases.
But in addition, sometimes data sets are of
high value, because they're unique and not
able to be replicated.
We have the process of determining high value
data set occurs at multiple times in the research
process.
First, of course, at the point of inception
of the original research that creates the
data set, it's worthy to think about what
might the future life of that data set be.
How long will it be useful?
Under what circumstances?
That will help guide subsequent decisions
about it.
Secondly, at the closing of a research process,
which is the point at which many of the curation
decisions are made, the determination, again,
of which aspects of the data set are high
value to must be preserved, helps to guide
investments in curation.
And subsequent to that, determining the high
value data set to help us in understanding
how to ensure that those data sets become
discoverable, knowable, and reachable by investigators
who intend to use them.
Essentially, a determination of high value
data sets leads us to being able to preserve
with a purpose.
There is no point in preserving every single
data element ever generated in research, but
we do need to be able to make preservation
decisions that are useful to the community
of discovery driven research, as well as useful
to the public as a whole.
So our preservation has to consider, for example,
how likely is a data set to be reused.
Is it going to be used by a small community
of people who are well familiar with the data
set?
Or is it a larger community that will have
interest in access in that data set?
We need to use the preservation strategies
to decide the nature of metadata that gets
attached to data sets, what type of storage
resource should it be in, and close and easily
accessible online, or is a tape backup safe
storage we use acceptable for a particular
data set?
Finally, the preservation helps us know how
to market the existence and the availability
of the data sets.
We talk a lot about metadata.
Metadata being the process of attaching information
to a data set, and to the data elements within
a data set.
We believe that using standard approaches
to these is the only way to ensure the findablilty
of the data sets.
And yet, generating standards is a complex
and task that needs to be undertaken in a
systematic fashion.
We see a lot of interest in the biological
communities, about community driven standards,
which are a reasonable starting point.
But as you see with the list of standards
across the bar in the center of this, the
kinds of standards we've used in clinical
data management, have been the result of balancing
individual unique communities, like being
a laboratory community being the clinical
care community.
With the other potential users, participants
in the data use.
RxNorm, for example, it's a merger of data
standards for medications that draw both from
the pharmaceutical companies, as well as from
the clinical care facilities.
We believe the National Library of Medicine
has a process in place, and a history of developing
standards, and can service both, as a clearinghouse
and as an integrator of standards.
We don't make the standards, but we make the
standards accessible.
Another aspect that the National Library of
Medicine is, keenly aware that we need to
invest in across elephant age, is generating
new tools for discovery and analysis.
The methodologies that
we have now, some are very specifically tied
to a specific data set or a specific domain
where the discoveries occurred, we're looking
to develop both deeply tied and analytical
methods that are unique to a particular areas,
as well as broad based ones, so we can get
efficiencies across our environments.
We see a great need for promoting training.
This session is but one of the approaches
to training development, that needs to be
brought forward to it as is to the society.
Training, we see it addressing three different
key groups.
The first, are basic data scientists.
These are the new algorithm developers, the
new methodological developers.
The second type of training we need, are data
sophisticated investigators, domain specific
investigators, who have the knowledge and
the insights of how to work with data science
and data scientists to enhance the discoveries
in their area.
And finally, we need data informed front-end
workers.
Be they clinicians, or librarians, or even
patients who are able to understand access
and make use of the products of data driven
science.
Data driven science doesn't happen alone,
and it's not only going to happen within the
NIH funded community, but it needs to be done
in partnership across the federal government,
across the international borders.
And we work very closely with the Welcome
Trust with GA4GH, and a number of groups that
are advancing standards and policies around
data sharing.
We recognize that data does not know country
boundaries, does not recognize, in science,
is not held by a single country.
The international efforts that the National
Library of Medicine has been engaged in for
years, will help guide us in the engagement
with our international partners to ensure
free flowing data and information around the
world.
I want to pause for just a minute to remind
you, that the endpoint of data science is
the health of individuals in our society.
And whether they be an investigator, such
as the woman on the left, or the clinician,
the gentleman on the right, or a patient,
we have an ultimate end user.
And while I don't expect every single scientist,
and every data scientist to have an outreach
component of their work that ensures that
the everyday layperson understands and benefits
from their work, I do believe it is a responsibility
of the NIH to make sure that our resources
and our discoveries are accessible and known
and useful to an extremely broad range of
individuals, including the very moment of
care at the end user place.
Let me close by talking a little bit about
where we're going next to the integration
with BD2K and the investments in new data
science tools, in the short run, in the next
few years at NIH.
The BD2K program has been quite a success
developing new methods giving us experience
with testing out, moving of data sets, integration
of data sets, and we will continue to build
with them.
The program, the BD2K program, has moved to
the common fund within our division of program
planning and evaluation.
And the BD2K program, investigators continue
to meet and are organized to Dr. Betsy Wilder's
office there, in the common fund.
The activities that the BD2K program is supporting,
right at this time-- from January of '17 through
August of '18-is to synthesize and collect
learnings from the centers of excellence,
of which there were 12, to conduct the
commons pilots.
Now this program name, in the last two weeks,
has changed to The Vanguard.
Within The Vanguard, what was originally known
as the commons pilots, three high value data
sets, TopMed, GTEX, and the MODS, have been
identified, and will be prepared for storage
in a common structure that will be a cloud
based structure.
The plan is to establish a foundation for
authentication, authorization, and curation
that is scalable, but specifically gives us
experience with taking high value data sets
and moving them into a cloud environment.
There will be much attention given to the
cost of managing data and moving data to a
cloud environment to make it more accessible,
make it more re-usable, and interoperable.
And also the experience of investigators,
and their investigator teams, at the institutions
both in terms of data deposit, as well as
in terms of actually using an operating on
the data.
We expect also to be stimulating new inquiry
in this area, and releasing at least one funding
announcement to specifically conduct analysis
on two or more of these high value data sets,
TopMed, GTEX, for example, or the MODS.
There will be a new funding opportunity released
this summer before the end of fiscal '17,
which will be done under our other transactions
authority.
So it won't be a research based grant, but
we're looking for partnerships to develop
the authentication and authorization strategies
to establish a curation approach, and also
to help with the logistics of making transitions
to cloud environments feasible for more people.
There continues to be investment in training
our BD2K T32 programs, are continuing.
And as I indicated earlier, there is an investment
in curation.
All of these have been currently funded, are
extensions into new programs awaits fiscal
'18, when I expect to see new funding announcements
come forward.
We are though, emphasizing our development
of the infrastructure on the NIH campus.
In front of you, is a picture of most of the
campus.
One of our big buildings to the right is missing.
That funny, diamond shaped building, with
the diamond shaped top, that's the National
Library of Medicine.
We're right at the front edge of the campus.
We will be building the commons framework,
as is depicted here.
And this is from Warren Kibbe and Vivien Bonazzi's
work to get you to understand, that what we
believe we're building at NIH is a compute
platform, that will be managed through commercial
cloud services.
We will be putting in place [INAUDIBLE] containers
for creating packaging of applications and
developing a digital object identifier process.
Test it out first with these three high value
data sets.
We are going to be integrating some of the
APIs that were developed under the BD2K program,
and developing new ones, and also enhancing
the search process and search for discoverability
and findability.
At the National Library of Medicine, we are
also involved in moving data science into
our portfolio.
We are in the process of partnering with groups
to work on creating the mechanisms to determine
high value data sets, and for creating
specifically forecasting cost and utilization
is the emphasis in the program we're doing
here.
We will be implementing efficient and secure
preservation strategies, to facilitate access
and reuse.
Beginning in December of this year, we will
be opening the PubMed Central to allow data
deposit with articles, as they are entered
into PubMed.
That will be our first step at opening a secure
preservation strategy that makes data accessible
through individual articles.
We will be continuing to stimulate intramural
efforts and standards development, and try
to bring some order of organization to the
standards processes.
Developing new methods for data management
and data driven discovery, our methodological
discoveries are emphasizing in the natural
language processing area, and in machine learning
specifically, for the short grow.
Our workforce investment continues.
Many of our NLM training programs now have
added a data science dimension.
We anticipate opening a new data management
training program, in the future.
Now in the T32, and perhaps the F31 mechanism,
we continue to engage across the government,
particularly with NSF, and with NOA to look
at safe and efficient strategies for data
management and storage.
And hope to be expanding this, and will be
expanding this, through collaborations with
others.
Finally, we are doing all of this under a
concept of fostering of the idea of open science,
of making science accessible to the community
to ensure that the process from discovery,
from an initial inception of what research
ideas are interesting to pursue, to what research
should be pursued, what funding should be
done to actually interpreting and disseminating
information, being done in a way that actually
brings more openness engaging industry, engaging
science, society, and also engaging the individuals,
who have the ability to lead in a scientific
workforce development.
Finally, we are absolutely committed to making
sure that the findings from the BD2K program
are in the Cloud Pilots, The Vangard program
now, are made available and accessible to
as broader a community as possible.
A key aspect of this, for our work here, is
going to be the establishment of a structure
for the development of data science infrastructure
at NIH.
And I deliberately selected this image of
this series of blocks, because what I envision
in the future, is we will have a highly distributed
data structure.
Our data commons at NIH will be but one of
the commons where data will be residing in
the future.
And our goals for developing this, and our
goals for making sure data are accessible
and knowable across a large community, require
us to have in place, a stable structure that
guides the acquisition in development and
distribution of data, as it goes forward.
I envision there will be a division with the
National Library of Medicine, that focuses
specifically on data science, and it will
partner with our science investigators around
the NIH, both in the intramural and the extramural
programs.
I also envision that their resources, that
are already in place in the National Library
of Medicine, will help us reach the public
better.
So our community of the national networks
of libraries of medicine, which provide us
with 6500 points of presence around the country,
will have, in place, libraries and library
resources that can
assist institutions, and universities, and
investigators, to develop effective methods
for working with data.
Increasingly, in our academic health science
centers, we're seeing that our librarians
are taking a key role in helping investigators
prepare their data for deposit, and also to
identify, and locate, and manage large data
sets, much the same way that we did the literature.
So the librarians aren't going to do the data
science, the same way the librarians didn't
do the basic science that created the articles
that grew out of investigations, but instead,
they're going to provide the facilitation,
the information infrastructure, for science.
We believe, also through the nationalized
network of libraries of medicine, that we
will be able to help the general public better
understand where our data driven discoveries
affect their lives.
For example, participants in All Of Us program,
which intends to obtain biological samples,
as well as other types of assessments from
over 1 million people, will be best served
if there's a library in the community that
can help people understand what it means when
one gets an individual test result back, or
an individual genetic profile back, through
the All Of Us program.
Having trusted information resources that
are able to support the data driven enterprise,
is both the end point of the data driven discovery
process, as well as a service that we believe
the government can provide.
I will leave you now with just one announcement
that you may have heard before, but an important
leader in the data science initiative at NIH
will be leading us.
Dr. David Lipman, the founding director of
the NCBI, is going to be stepping down next
week after almost 30 years of service to NIH.
He greatly improved their access to biomedical
information and genomic information.
His discoveries of blasts, his standing up
in the dbGaP, that is critical, important
offerings from the National Library of Medicine
and the NIH.
Dr. Litmus is making a major career change.
He's going to be assuming the position of
the chief science officer at Impossible Foods,
which is a new company in California that's
applying molecular biology to the food industry
to create vegan based foods.
We wish Dr. Lipman his great success, but
recognize that many of the comments that I
made today, and mention the vision of data
science at NIH, was shaped by this brilliant
colleague, and I am grateful for his work.
I'll close by-- oh, got one more picture him,
sorry.
Dr. Lipman was around at the very beginning
of the development of the NCBI.
You see him here with Claude Pepper and Dr.
[INAUDIBLE], as they were discussing the launch
of NCBI, before it became what it is today,
which was a great and incredible resource
for data.
And I close by now showing you that you can
reach me in many ways.
Through a blog called Musings From The Mezzanine,
which focuses on the National Library of Medicine
resources.
Another blog called Data Science at NIH, which
focuses on our data science activities here.
I'm on Twitter and pretty active.
And I'm also available by email.
I now hope I've given us enough time to have
some conversation about the directions for
the future, and I welcome your thoughts and
your ideas.
Thanks very much.
Dr. Brennan, thank you so much for that wonderful
overview of data science from the NIH.
It seems very comprehensive, and a lot of
thought seems to have gone into what the future
of data science is going to be at the NIH.
Moving forward, there are a number of questions,
as you might imagine, from a comprehensive
talk like yours.
I probably can't get to all of them, but per
your request, I will try and copy all of them,
and I'll forward them to you, so that you
can kind of get a sense of the things that
people are curious about.
But I'll sample a few and maybe you can address
them.
I know that there was a lot of discussion
about the commons and about the role that
that's going to play, and there were some
questions about the role of existing kind
of data sharing efforts that are being done
through the NIH.
For example, like the National Cancer Institute's
genomics data commons, I know there's some
work that was spearheaded, formerly by Dr.
Insel at the NIMH, for example the Autism
Centers of Excellence, where you're expected
to provide your data as a condition of your
funding to the national database of autism
research, and other programs.
How will those play a role?
Will they benefit?
Will they become partners in the new data
commons?
How do you see that working?
Well I'm going to take you back to my-- I
hope I'm going to take you back to my slide--
to show you that the structure that we envision
is, if you will, a highly distributed structure.
So the NIH data commons will be but one of
what we envision as a whole network of commons,
as in data repositories, around the world.
And are our challenges in creating proper
discovery mechanisms, catalogs, for example,
it's not dissimilar to the challenge that
was originally faced when the World Wide Web
and the domain name servers had to come about.
So we're at the beginning of needing to be
able to locate and share at the level of repositories,
and then at the level of data sets.
We envision that-- we worked very closely
with Warren Kibbe and the Cancer Genome commons,
and also with the Brain Initiative, with the
Autism commons-- and we do not see those as
being, in any way, closed by this process,
by creating an NIH data commons.
But rather, the NIH data commons is yet another
participant in this activity of data sharing.
Now I will say, that at this point in time,
all of the focus in developing the NIH commons
is targeted around known data sets.
And we see going forward, that the models
for curating known data sets might be slightly
different than the models for creating new
data sets.
And again, we're working with a trans NIH
group, to make sure that we first of all,
don't tie ourselves to an our archiving model,
that actually isn't as robust as the future
we'll need, but second, so that we don't lose
our connections to those models.
Let me say, just briefly, we expect that we
will be connecting, the data commons infrastructure,
will connect to data commons.
Are there other data repositories held in
different places, including within universities,
including at research institutes, and in other
countries.
The negotiation of what constitutes access,
exchange, what kinds of compute resources
are going to be available, will, I believe,
make for a of substantial amount of conversation,
as well as indexing of resources over the
next few
years.
We're in an early stage of this.
We fundamentally believe the distributed structure
is essential.
When one makes a commitment to a distributed
structure, one makes a commitment to invest
in discovery tools, as much as analytic tools.
That was another kind of series of questions
had to do with.
The role of tools, even though the commons
is being constructed now, at the NIH itself,
do you envision future opportunities for people
who develop tools, which leverage the commons
and the data in it and it's metadata, as part
of some of your new funding initiatives that
you see on the horizon.
Absolutely.
I'm quite committed to accelerating methods
developments, which is a necessary precursor
to accelerating knowledge development.
We are considering, for example, what does
a library of models look like?
How do we curate models the way we curate
the literature, so an executable version of
a model becomes accessible and knowable?
So we anticipate that we're going to have
to invest in three areas, with respect to
models.
First, of course, model development.
And we work with the intergovernment modeling
analysis and simulation group, on the beginning
parts of the step.
But in addition, we know we need to find a
way to distribute models more effectively
than in the text narrative of an article,
or as an appendage to an article.
So we are looking to find a mechanism for
constructing model libraries, discoverable
miles of libraries.
And finally, we need to find ways where we
can efficiently link models and data sets,
in a way that allows them to be interrogated,
but isn't terribly redundant, or complex in
its organization.
And by that, I mean, that as a model is modified
for a particular data set, it is really important
to be able to recover that exact instance
of the model with that data set, if one wants
to try to reproduce a set of findings.
And the way we do this in the literature right
now, is we have a citation database, we have
investigators describe their background or
place their working in a certain scientific
tradition, and then use text to describe the
procedures they will be doing to carry out
an experiment, or that they did use to carry
out an experiment.
As we move into data driven discovery, we
need to be thinking about different ways of
documenting the scientific process, as well
as archiving that documentation.
So I see a whole range of new scientific communication
tools emerging, along with the discovery tools,
and the analytical tools.
It's very interesting that you mentioned libraries.
One of the things that, at least I have learned
through our running of these data science
seminar series, is the interest and potential
source of energy, if you will, that comes
from librarians and library scientists, and
their potential role here.
And we had a question from someone asking,
will the National Library of Medicine be hiring
additional librarians who have data science
experience, following a trend across the country
apparently.
This is a great question.
It would surprise-- maybe not everyone, but
certainly surprised me when I first came here
last summer-- that we have 1700 men and women
that work here at the National Library of
Medicine, and we only have 97 librarians.
Which tells you that the work of a library
takes a lot of different disciplines together,
the least of which is librarians.
We do anticipate that our library operations
group, which manages the collection that we
have, that is, what do we physically own,
as well as the curation our Medline literature
citation process, will be enriched with individuals
who will be helping with the data curation
process.
What we expect to have happen, and I anticipated
the development of something that might look
like a PubMed for data.
Now people here don't like to say it quite
that way, because it's not a direct equivalent,
but just as we have a archive tagging system,
JATS system, we are in the process of working
with the biocaddie group to refine the DATS,
D-A-T-S, which is a data archiving tagging
system.
So we'll be able to put a high level metadata
structure that enable us to catalog data.
That will require that we use the library
science skills, and cataloging, and creating,
and indexing, so individuals can find the
data sets.
And just as we don't hold every article that
is listed in Medline we would not hold the
owner of every data set that is listed in
a data catalog, but rather provide the pathway
to it.
I see librarians as having two other really
key roles.
Librarians, if brought into a research projects
from the very beginning, can help the research
team describe the data management plan, in
a way that addresses sustainability.
And ensures that the metadata, even early
curation can occur, as data is being acquired,
not simply waiting until the data set is complete.
And the second aspect is that our library
science community is going to be of great
assistance to our investigators.
And frankly, to the public in general-- small
businesses, industry-- in actually locating
data sets.
Because the process of searching for data
sets and locating them is not nearly as refined
as the process of searching for the literature.
So we'll need all the library science talent
we can get.
That's probably going to be good news to a
number of people.
You mentioned data sharing plans.
And I know that the NIH has been very interested
in increasing the description of how people
will be sharing their data across a variety
of grants, typically these have been at the
more expensive end of the grant spectrum,
if you will, but this is increasingly suspected
that it's going to be coming down to R01s
and R21s, et cetera.
How does the commons play into that, or inform,
that policy of what could be shared, and when
it can be shared, under the grant mechanism
framework?
So this is a really good question.
And some of you may be familiar with the rather
strong separation between intramural and extramural
research at the NIH, but in the data science,
particularly in the data sharing process,
those two areas get blended quite quickly.
We envision that publicly funded research,
and the data generated through publicly funded
research, should be available to the public.
That's an open science framework.
So having
said that, we need to find ways to help investigators,
in an efficient way, be able to make their
data sharable.
And that is the basis underlying the idea
of the commons.
There will be a safe place for the data to
reside.
Now if we start thinking about the 18,000
NIH funded projects, that are going on on
this very day, that's a lot of different data
sets to archive, and to think that they will
continue to be growing.
So we would expect that there will be-- not
so much from the commons, but through our
office of science policy, and through our
materials in the funding announcements, and
in the guides-- there will be guidance, regarding
how to prepare a data set for a deposit.
How to determine which parts of the data set
need to be shared.
How to identify an acceptable storage opportunity
for a data set, because we don't envision
ever requiring that all data generated in
all NIH projects, be only stored at the NIH,
but rather that we foster the use of appropriate
types of archiving for the data, and appropriate
types of discoverability.
I must comment, for just a moment, on the
idea of what we call deaccessioning data sets.
When a data set is no longer actively used,
or actively in need, we need to have policies
in place that describe what happens next.
Does it go to a lower, long term storage environment?
Does it remain in an index?
Do we need to retain all of the modeling that
was done with the data set to ensure that
it can continue to be used?
Those questions, now, are going to require
extensive comment from the community, as well
as propose as plans developed here at the
NIH.
That's great.
One question-- this is sort of a two pronged
question, if you'll indulge me for a second--
but we've got a number of questions about
this, so I'm trying to synthesize.
I always think you mention the fair principles,
and we don't need to go into what they all
mean, but I've always kind of secretly felt
that there is a silent "E" on the end of fair,
that you don't hear, but that stands for education
and training.
And that the role of education and training
in data science is absolutely fundamental
to, not only helping people who are not biomedical
scientists, but from statisticians and computer
scientists get into looking at these very
rich sources of data.
I want to hear a little bit more about what
you feel the role of education will be, but
also how that touches on the role of trust,
which you also mention, in terms of public
outreach.
I think now we're about two or three weeks
after the March for Science, and the notion
of trustworthiness and science and maybe some
distrust from certain portions of the American
population.
I think that's an important role, and I want
to hear what your thoughts are on that.
Well you don't become a data scientist at
the PhD level.
You have to begin thinking about data science
from the K12 experience.
So we are partnering with the NSF to look
at how we can influence and strengthening
the foundations for data science in the K-12
education program.
Children who are exposed to probability theory,
and fourth graders, and nuances about algebra,
by the time they're in the sixth grade, will
do much better in the future.
And we will be able to concentrate our university
based data science training building on the
substrate of knowledge that individuals bring
at that moment.
We also have to think about the generations
of investigators, and analysts, and librarians,
and clinicians who are in their 30s, 40s,
and 50s, who grew up with experimental models
of knowledge building and evidence generation,
and need to move over into complement that--
not replace it completely-- but complement
it with data science.
So I would envision that we will have our
future training, NIH funded training, will
include early career, mid-career opportunities
for investigators to get deeper training in
the data sciences.
We expect to be partnering with the Medical
Library Association, and with our library
colleagues through the Association of Research
Libraries, to build effective, in the moment
training for our workers, who need to have
access to understanding about data science
and where it fits into the process of inquiry,
but don't have the ability to leave to get
another degree.
That's great.
Did you have any final thoughts on public
outreach and how the data science commons
might help with that?
Well, I believe that our ability to be transparent--
and I'm demonstrating why scientific conclusions
arose and the pathways from which they arose--
will enhance the public trust.
I believe that at the National Library of
Medicine, in particular, and the NIH in general,
enjoys a great deal of the public trust.
And so the strategies that we take to make
data accessible, not only through the scientific
channels, but also through public libraries,
is an important part of how we will be engendering
trust from the public.
At the same time, we have to help the public
develop numeracy and an understanding of probabilistic
and thinking, because-- not at the same depth
of an investigator-- but we need to move from
a society that largely views points as truisms,
to understanding ranges and pathways and patterns,
so that we don't oversell the result that
a particular study or a particular investigation
provides.
And again, the idea of building a quantitatively
sophisticated public, will require us engaging
at the very earliest levels.
Well with that, I'd like to thank you so much,
Dr. Brennan, for that wonderful overview of
NIH data science thinking.
The pathway forward and some of the details
about how you envision that happening.
I think this was outstanding.
In an outstanding way to end our series of
data science seminars, funded through the
BD2K program, which have been just so wonderfully
attended.
And so I want to thank all of our attendees
for their participation, and any feedback
that you have will be welcomed to receive
that.
So once again, thank you so much.
And thank you, Dr. Brennan.
Thank you, John.
And I'll comment on some of the items in my
blog, if it's possible to do so, so keep watching.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, everybody.